miles de mujeres caminan por las calles
de madrid pidiendo igualdad real de
derechos y la eliminación de la
violencia de género tras dos años de
pandemia que han exacerbado las
disparidades entre hombres y mujeres el
8 de marzo llega con diferencias en la
lista de reclamos de las feministas lo
que ha desembocado en dos
manifestaciones distintas en la ciudad
por un lado está la organizada por la
comisión 8 m que marcha bajo el lema
derechos para todas todos los días esto
va de que todos seamos iguales en un
mundo equitativo que tengamos también
las mismas oportunidades laborales
económicas y sobre todo la violencia de
género que
o sea es como la punta del iceberg pero
detrás de este feminicidio ya asesinato
hay todo un bloque de violencia
psicológica económica social que no
tenemos por qué aguantar las mujeres por
otro lado está la organizada por el
movimiento feminista que según ellas
defienden la auténtica agenda feminista
que para el movimiento tiene que ser
abolicionista
y el feminismo de base está en contra de
cualquier explotación hacia la mujer
está estamos en contra de la
prostitución estamos en contra de la
pornografía estamos en contra los
juguetes de alquiler y el que haya dos
manifestaciones separadas no crees que
diluye el mensaje principal que es la
defensa de los derechos de la mujer no
no tiene por qué para nada creo que
estamos unidad en que queremos que las
mujeres tenemos que defender nuestros
derechos pese a las discrepancias que
hemos escuchado en ambas marchas el
mensaje principal de mantener sanas y
salvas a las mujeres está presente un
mensaje muy importante en un país en el
que el 20 por ciento de los hombres
entre los 15 y los 29 años creen que la
violencia de género es una invención
ideológica